pretty unpredictable what percent let's
go into vets what percent of um bats are
women double okay
so it's 60 it's so it's still close to
15. no it's over 60 I said double so
it's like okay
I just was expecting like because in the
industries I mentioned it's like 95 men
it's not close to 50 50. you don't think
you've got two-thirds I don't I don't
think that's the same as 95 I think men
have been working for a lot longer than
women I mean so I think women are still
trying to come into their fields you
know there's some women that are still
relying on men some women are still
relied on their parents even you know
there's women that are in their 20s and
they're still relying that's just an
excuse if you're born today you have no
barriers they're absolutely that's fine
but in regards to like trying to move up
and trying to get further in your career
not just getting into a career entry
level it can be difficult